October 24 2007 dear mr. gold I have
been studying box last great
instrumental composition the art of the
few for quite some time now there's a
cannon from an earlier version of box
score that was published only after you
died it's too bad you didn't get to
record it I'm sure you would have so I
am going to do it this is my gift to you
I hope you like it sincerely he'll don't
so with my second teacher when I was
Rick when I was learning all the
inventions after I finished and I made
just a recording for myself she gave me
this CD of Glenn Gould and said this is
Glenn Gould do not copy him so i went
home and listen to it and at first it
was really striking because it was so
odd and we'd never heard anything like
it I mean the first invention when the
first couple of notes come in it's
pretty normal for everybody but when the
second voice comes in it was so clear
and so it had such a fire underneath it
that it kept me it kept making you
listen and usually I listened to one
piece not the whole set but after this I
listen to like all 15 of them at a time
instead of just one of them and after
you listed all 15 of them you realize
what a genius he is because each one is
so unique and they're all so special but
they're all unified and the ideas and
each one are so peculiar that sometimes
you're kind of wondering wait why does
he even do that it sounds not quite
right and after listening to that we
gave the CD back to my teacher and she's
like you didn't coffee him right I said
no I didn't copy and she's like okay
good
the first city was the inventions the
two-part interventions that my piano
teacher gave to me she loaned it to me
then I went home and I bought it and my
mom bought it off of amazon I think
listen to it we loved listening to it so
we found more of his recordings and the
most famous one is the Goldberg
Variations so we bought both the 1955 in
the 1981 we also bought the sweets the
partidos the English sweets the French
sweets and I think just a couple of
years ago just two years ago I think we
there is a LP boxed Glenn Gould memorial
set or something like that I think
celebrating his 25th anniversary of his
death and so we bought the whole thing
it was two hundred dollars but now I
have a big box in my bedroom with 80
Glenn Gould CDs in it and a nice thick
booklet with his own writing on each one
of those cds
I think she was kind of intrigued by his
unique interpretations of course if I
trying to convey him it would not be
very good but I think she just didn't
want me to play that out of the box
because his interpretations at that time
to her I think were really crazy and I
think some of them were a bit
unacceptable but she just wanted me to
listen to them so I could see how other
people played it